bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy
in an interest bearing account or you
can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang got a very
special treat for you today
i have chris and jake here thank you
both so much for taking the time to
record this
glad to be with you absolutely
um let's just jump right into uh your
backgrounds we've got a whole bunch of
stuff to go through today on the
regulatory front
but uh maybe jake we'll start with you
kind of talk through a little bit about
your background and what you're doing
now and then chris will go to you
okay sure uh i started i got a degree in
computer science
and uh my first part of my career was in
technology
i ran a software services firm for many
years
uh and in about 2014 i started to do
early stage angel investing
i was a part of several accelerators out
in los angeles
and uh and and did a lot of seed stage
equity investing
i started to invest in my first uh
bitcoin i'm sorry blockchain companies
in about 2015
and i invested in bitcoin in about 2016.
i think my first you bitcoin were 455
so then in about 2017 i started to think
about a real career shift
um i wanted to blend my background of
technology
and my passion for investing and i
really just dove down the crypto rabbit
hole
i started uh tradecraft capital uh we're
a crypto
fund and uh we've been going strong
and i think of last i just i have a
lookout uh
crypto asset investing in the age of
autonomy and that's
a little my history awesome chris
jake my entire career has been spent in
the triangle of
of markets technology and law i spent my
first 16 years as a
lawyer in new york and london
representing technology companies
selling their
products and services in the united
states and also raising
uh capital in the u.s and actually
began a a a legal series called
e-securities looking at some of the
first trading of securities online
and then in the year 2000 i left law and
teamed up with a startup called gfi
group and we built some of the first
electronic trading systems in the world
global networks for trading a type of
product called credit default swaps and
other derivatives
online and we became the largest network
global network for trading these
products and then
uh we took the we raised private equity
and then 2005 we took the company public
uh on the nasdaq and uh it was a great
success story and then my
third career after law and business was
to go to the cftc
at the invitation of president barack
obama and then become chairman at the
invitation of president trump and to be
uh surprisingly unanimously confirmed
twice
which was a great honor to me and to
serve as chairman of the agency
during a time when the agency really
took its first actions with regard to
the creation of cryptocurrency
derivatives and we greenlighted the very
first
uh uh bitcoin futures products to trade
on the exchange
which really was the beginning of an
institutional marketplace
uh for uh crypto because only when
you could actually short the price as
well as go long could institutional
money come into the space
and i think the explosion we're seeing
now is directly as a result of that
and now i left the agency in 2019 at the
end of my five-year term
and i'm engaged in a whole range of
activities both as
a board and advisor to a number of
crypto companies
and also as a senior counsel to
wilkeffer and gallagher a prominent
u.s firm law firm and then finally as
the
founding one of the founders of the
digital dollar project which is
a think tank to examine the
challenges and opportunities of a u.s
central bank digital currency what we
call a digital dollar
absolutely and both of you have uh have
been around for a long time and been
integral to a lot of progress
um chris maybe let's start the
regulatory conversation with just
uh your evaluation you were one of the
top regulators
and kind of heads of one of the most
important agencies uh just where
are we right now when it comes to uh
crypto
and kind of this age of autonomy uh that
i think jake refers
to uh but where are we from a regulation
standpoint today and how do you view
that
you know regulation always
follows innovation uh and and in fact i
think
that's a good thing you wouldn't want
regulation
getting out in front and actually laying
down a framework that innovation has to
innovate too
much better that innovation follows uh
customer demand
follows the natural course of innovation
and regulation follows up
and and certainly that was the case with
the early phase the first phase of the
internet the internet of information
but but that phase was different than
this phase because that phase
because it was about information and
because we have a first amendment
making sure that that speech
is private that innovation basically
came about in a regulatory
light zone we don't have federal bureaus
of community of information um
uh although we have a federal
communication commission that regulates
entities it doesn't
regulate speech and so the first wave at
the end of the
internet really evolved in a very sort
of a
a low resistance environment but this
wave of the internet the internet of
value
where things of value are becoming
digitized and decentralized
is really running into a regulatory
heavy zone
we have not one but two market
regulators in washington
looking out for people's interests in
marketplaces the cftc and the sec
we have not one but three banking
regulators in washington between the fed
the occ and the fdic
looking out for uh the regulation of
banks
and and other financial intermediaries
and then of course you've got regulation
at every state level
our legal system has long presumed that
the
the right and the authority of the state
to regulate
things of value for the protection of
consumers of things of value
and so this wave of innovation is
running headlong
into a regulatory structure that was
many cases
at the state level is centuries old at
the federal level goes back to the 1930s
it's an old regulatory framework that is
is being hit
smack on by a new wave of technological
innovation
digitization and decentralization and
the clash
is is pretty outs extraordinary
and it's one that we're going to have to
resolve as a society and i'm hopeful
that federal officials will regulate or
recognize
the uh antiquated nature of our of our
regulatory system
and in the in the both the challenges
but also the benefits
of this new wave of innovation uh of
things of value
and we will get some frameworks that
will be much more um
holistic and suitable for this this wave
of innovation
hope springs eternal uh but i am hopeful
we will get there
absolutely and jake i know that you've
done a bunch of work
on uh kind of these long uh wave cycles
um and so chris does a great job
articulating uh the current
environment maybe help us get some
historical context is this
normal how did we get here and how do
you think of it in
context with those long wave cycles
yeah i think you know my thesis is that
we've begun a new long wave cycle
we know that the the five to ten year
cycles those short term cycles
are driven by credit but those long wave
cycles
those 50 to 60 year cycles are driven by
innovation or technological revolution
carleto perez does a great job in her
book
technological revolutions and financial
capital
outlying the the past 200 years and
really going through the
age of industry cars and autos
electrification um and
uh blast the age of information that we
are in and i think we've seen
evidence that a new cycle has begun
about a decade ago we started to see
that i ai iot and robotics
were delivering on uh on automation
and that was powerful it just wasn't
transformational it didn't change
how businesses went about operating
um cryptocurrency really was the the
last piece of that puzzle
because it allows us to process store
and transfer economic value without
human intervention
and so as these four technologies
converge
we're seeing more and more autonomy
autonomous operations
um i can see in the not too distant
future
all businesses building autonomous
operations
simply because you know those businesses
that don't have autonomous operations
simply won't be able to compete because
autonomy really is the ultimate
competitive advantage
and so all of these uh technologies are
converging
with blockchain and with crypto assets
and
um that new long wave cycle i believe
is the age of autonomy that's what i
call it so yeah and we're you know
that that that autonomy is already
taking place
as a social construct as a result of the
covet pandemic
you know we we've all left our office
towers and we're all working in remote
sites and yet coming together
it you know through through the through
the genius of the internet through
the the force of the internet but
socially we're all accustoming to
this decentralization because it's
happening in our own lives
there's also you know one more thing is
um
the autonomy and of being autonomous is
one piece of a longer trend i think it
was
buckminster fuller who had this great uh
uh line about ephemeralization you know
it's the process
of doing more and more with less and
less
until eventually you can do everything
with nothing
and really autonomy is a just one of
cycle
one phase within that much longer cycle
and we're seeing evidence of that those
that could adapt be more ephemeral
during the pandemic
survived those that couldn't didn't as
much
yeah and chris maybe we can move to you
to talk a little bit about
kind of the improvement to the
regulatory environment in light of that
historical context and these kind of
long-wave cycles
um i've had uh lawyers come on uh before
specifically a gentleman named dave
rodman who's focused a lot on
decentralization and so
you know if you kind of really highlight
a specific uh
kind of area where technology appears to
be way ahead of the law would be
something like these dows ready to
decentralize
autonomous organization and so for
something as simple as
hey if you want to create a dao uh there
is no legal protection equivalent to an
llc
and so maybe there should be or there
shouldn't be and so
if you kind of take that as a micro
example but
you can look out at the macro and really
see that
there is a kind of uh difference or
there is some sort of
divergence between where the technology
is and where the law is how do we
think through improving the regulatory
environment what can regulators do today
to kind of position themselves to be
ready but also not to get ahead of
themselves and really
force people to innovate towards
regulation
so so the the regulatory phase
that has that has taken place the last
four or five years
up to the present and continuing in the
present
is one of very uh sort of an ad hoc
uh uh um
idiosyncratic response it has really
been driven
by uh the particular approach of the
leadership of the different agencies
and their their openness or resistance
to this innovation that has driven their
agency response
without an overall game plan
across agencies you know my experience
in both the obama and trump
administrations is
that uh my agency the cfdc uh
uh took on these issues pretty much on
on its own with with with with um
information and transparency to our
sister agencies in the federal
government
but without any sense of coordination or
or overall game plan
and that continued right i think through
the end of the trump administration
and and certainly what's going on at the
state level as well between state and
federal
there isn't a lot of coordination it is
really more idiosyncratic now
um uh in the new incoming administration
there are some key appointments of of
people uh gary gensler at the sec
potentially michael barr at occ
potentially chris brummer
at the cftc of individuals who in their
outside of government have really taken
the time to drill down and understand
crypto and and the ecosystem in which it
operates and
the trends that are at play and uh it i
think it brings the potential
for a more coordinated approach and
certainly gary gensler
at his prior time during the obama
administration
had a large hand in crafting dodd-frank
but then implementing it
at the cftc so i think the prospect for
a more coordinated
uh a comprehensive approach from the
federal government to
bringing regulation to the space is is
is
the potential is there but the current
environment is still
one of rather ad hoc and i haven't heard
anything from the biden administration
suggesting
yet a comprehensive approach to this
there are certainly calls for it in
congress there's a number of
key committee leaders who who recognize
the need for this but whether they
will be able to advance legislation uh
whether the incoming administration
will will embrace that remains to be
seen so right now
in this phase uh uh in the second decade
of the
the 21st century and the um
uh the approach remains
rather ad hoc and so the choices for
agency leadership
are vitally important as to whether they
are you know to use the old
um crossing the chasm analogy of early
adopters late adopters you know the
earlier adopters can
provide leadership the late adopters can
provide resistance
and it remains a scene who remains to be
seen who congress
uh uh confirms for these positions and
what leadership role the byte
administration may choose to take if at
all
yeah and even though go ahead sorry no
jake oh it's just that even though it
was idiosyncratic
thank god we had some early adopters in
those agencies like chris
as crypto dad and hester purse at the
sec as crypto mom
to be to to see the vision and and be
those early adopters
um because they really laid the
groundwork for what's possible today
i just wanted to thank you and we did
and
you know when we we we advocated for
that early adoption approach and made
our points and yet
other agencies you know may not have
taken or followed our lead some of some
of my
uh fine colleagues when i served as
chairman
um said fine we're we're fine with you
uh
allowing bitcoin futures to go forward
but we're not gonna do the same thing at
our agency
we just don't have the comfort level
with it and so
you know that that idiosyncratic
approach resulted in
a rather uneven uh and for
for the ecosystem or rather uncertain uh
environment to operate
you know as someone who uh ran a
business and took a
business public you know the uncertainty
is is very very it's very hard to
innovate
um business practices customer services
new products in an uncertain regulatory
environment that's what we have today
and
during my time at the cftc we within our
own jurisdiction
we provide we tried to provide more
certainty but until there's an overall
federal embrace and you know we did have
that in the
first phase of the internet you know
congress under republican leadership the
white house under democratic leadership
came together
and adopted a policy called do no harm
for the very first phase of the internet
which resulted in
amazing american leadership in that
first phase of the internet in the 1990s
and beyond
we just don't have that commonality of
purpose uh
today and and as a result um
while america is do certainly in the
private sector doing some amazing
innovation
the united states just is not having
that that overall
prominence in this innovation uh that we
had
last time around and maybe you know for
for a global environment
it's good that development is taking
place everywhere but i would like to see
the united states show more consistent
leadership
provide a more comprehensive regulatory
environment that's easier to navigate
for innovators jake if if we kind of
zoom out a little bit and we take the
innovative forward thinking approach
that uh chris is outlining here from a
regulatory and legal standpoint
uh what does the future look like right
i know that you've got some uh some
pretty
aggressive yet uh pretty rational uh
thoughts in terms of where what this is
going and so maybe let's look forward
you know 20 25 years like what does the
world look like and how do you see it
being different than it is today
yeah definitely well i want to talk a
little bit about
what we have today and why um you know
we're seeing in the news with with
michael saylor
buying bitcoin or with elon musk
uh putting significant you know
corporate uh treasury management
allocation like
you know one and a half billion dollars
to bitcoin why
why are these uh investors coming to the
mat
and putting money in there and i think
ultimately
we're all seeing what's going on with
with us dollars and
printing of bank reserves and a little
bit unsure and uncertain about what that
type of future will
lead to and so um we're seeing a lot of
headlines
about sound money policy and being able
to
adopt into some money policy by
you know by the investment into bitcoin
um
kind of that way it is just starting
with uh
with east coast finance getting their
feet wet with bitcoin
west coast tech in asia is really
focused on
defy or decentralized finance the
purpose of that is
obviously to create a decentralized
approach
in building financial services like the
traditional financial system
and uh and the killer app of that is
yield right
uh we're not we're not seeing much yield
in traditional finance and so
um that's what's so appealing about
decentralized finance
um those all are still financial capital
you know the this first decade or two
we're still talking about financial
capital
um one thing i want to bring into the
picture is the idea of
production capital um you can think of
production capital
like in the agrarian age would be farms
and livestock
or in the industrial age factories and
raw material
or the age of information intellectual
property
and all of these rights really are the
things that accrue value
in the age of autonomy we're going to
have new production capital
um dows and dax and autonomous protocols
and several crypto primitives that are
going to accrue value
i can easily see in the future that an
autonomous protocol
as production capital will accrue and be
more valuable than any factory in the
future
ever and so what is important is to
think about
both production capital and financial
capital and how that's going to affect
and transform the world and uh be
mindful of that as we
look to innovate and then regulate
you know pop what's so interesting i
think right now and building on what
what jake just said is it's not
surprising
that a time of enormous expansionary
monetary policy
that uh investors are looking to hedge
their exposure
to the dollar um in a
in into a stable non-expansionary
instrument
it's happened every time and most often
they've gone to silver and gold but
what's what
is amazing is that this is the first
time i think in human history
where the hedge is in a decentralized
digital asset and that's what is so i
think
remarkable is that that
that the digitization of the economy has
now provided the first
sort of a large-scale investment
opportunity
uh away from expansionary monetary
policy into a new asset class that
didn't exist before a digital asset
class
bitcoin and so when you guys think
through
um kind of how this uh
is evolving today i want to bring it
back to the kind of um
you know existing moment or right now
how do you look at
various um you know kind of efforts and
uh chris you've been very involved and
let's take like the digital dollar
uh initiative maybe you can talk a
little bit just about like
why choose that route to uh pursue
um as a way to kind of push the
regulatory conversation and then after
you get done with that jpeg you can talk
a little bit from a technology
standpoint how
innovators are saying look we may not be
able to create the laws or may not be
able to create the regulations but here
are some projects that people are doing
to really push the pace
uh of innovation and hopefully pull
regulators in the right direction
so so pop i mentioned earlier that you
know regula regulation
naturally fought and should naturally
follow innovation
um and that our our regulatory system is
is
fairly old and in some ways is
antiquated certainly was built for
an analog human world not not a digital
automated world
and has to catch up but there's another
factor as well
is that i don't know why and i think it
has something to do with some degree
of of sort of maybe cultural immaturity
or something
but we've been pretty neglectful uh in
the united states and in the west
of our of our overall infrastructure
whether it's our physical infrastructure
our bridges and our tunnels our airports
our railroads
which were once state of the art in the
mid 20th centuries
are pretty antiquated in the 21st
century and we've been fairly relaxed
about it
for some reason we keep talking about
infrastructure improvements
in congress and elsewhere but we haven't
done much to update it well the same is
true
a lot about our financial market
infrastructure you know systems for
payment and settlement
that were once state of the art uh in
the last century
you know on a global on a global
relative basis are pretty antiquated
and obsolete in the 21st century and
again
we haven't taken that seriously enough
and so nothing is more central to
financial market infrastructure than
currency itself you can consider it like
the rails for a railroad a currency
a national currency is what everything
in the economy is built on
here we are moving forward into a
digital economy
and yet our currency is still an analog
instrument
and we're not taking seriously the
challenge to that instrument
money has always competed in global
markets
once upon a time during the european
exploration of the east coast of the
western hemisphere
there were many european currencies in
competition with one another
it was it was british pounds and french
francs and dutch gilders
but the currency that was in most demand
was the dollar but it wasn't the us
dollar it was the spanish dollar
and the reason why the spanish dollar
was the currency to have
was because it had technological
superiority over the others
it was minted with new world silver
which was more consistently pure
than old world silver meaning it needed
less alloy making it
lighter but also more consistently pure
but it was minted in a way that can be
broken up into eight pieces known as
pieces of eight making it fractionable
requiring it more easy to use in
commerce so
technological advantages of one currency
over another are
reasons why they get preferred in global
commerce
now we assume the dollar it's the
world's reserve currency it will
be you know that way forever but why
should we assume that
china is rolling out a digital yuan
that's going to be fractionable that is
going to be digital that is going to be
able to be used in peer-to-peer
transactions
it's going to have technological
superiority to analog instruments
we need to take seriously the
modernization of the dollar for a
digital and
digital future in the same way we need
to take seriously the need to
update our railroads update our airports
update all of our physical
infrastructure
we need to update our economic
infrastructure as well and nothing is
more core
to an economy than the currency that
upon which it's built
we need to digitize the dollar for a
digital future and i can go on and on
and talk about
the the need to be able to make a
programmable dollar so we can attach
smart contracts to it
so that we can use it in peer-to-peer
transactions so we can
drive greater financial inclusion by a
young society that's
very accustomed using mobile devices but
less comfortable with walking into banks
so there's a lot of reasons to modernize
the dollar but at the end of the day
it's just that it comes down to do we
have the courage to modernize our
financial infrastructure
we've lacked the courage to modernize
our physical infrastructure it's time
we took a more mature attitude in a
global competitive economy
we've got we can't take anything for
granted we need to modernize
our economy we need to monetize our
monetary system and we need to monetize
our money jake maybe talk a little bit
about how you see the innovation playing
out so
chris talked a lot about kind of the
global uh competition if you will right
basically that there's different
regulators in different
uh geographic regions and they're all
going to take
different approaches but the united
states the hope is that we can continue
to be
the leader on that global stage uh how
do you see this playing out from an
innovation standpoint yeah well pom as
you know
good innovators are either solving a
problem or meeting a need
and really bitcoin is solving a problem
and meeting a need
right we have uh we don't have a real
store of value
right now bitcoin is solving that we
really don't
have yields because we're we're
manipulating
you know the price of money
decentralized finance
allows uh to build and generate yield
what's really interesting about building
a decentralized
financial system on sound money
principles
is that you need collateral uh to
initiate loans
and so uh one thing i want people to get
is
yes uh bitcoin is you know digital gold
and
and um an inflation hedge or a hedge
against monetary expansion
but it also is a really pristine
probably the most pristine [ __ ]
you know reserve asset bitcoin and ether
can be used as
reserve assets to really
be the foundation of this new
decentralized financial system
any new system starts with being able to
do collateralized loans
that that's the first thing in
capitalism that you need to be able to
do
and we're already seeing that uh now in
d5
innovators are building insurance
companies
and exchanges and derivative projects
uh uh just all kinds of
uh innovation that you're seeing uh so
that
people can take advantage and use crypto
assets
in novel ways innovation will continue
into the business operations as i was
talking about
businesses will be able to be more and
more competitive
the more and more they become autonomous
or build autonomous operations i mean
you can think about
if you know when uber has autonomous
cars
um you know how much uh
more capable
they're going to be to meet the needs of
their market
um they're going to be more competitive
uh
that's going to continue and the
innovation cycle is going to continue
it really is competition that is the
disbursement and death and
distribution mechanism uh of that
long wave technological cycle and so um
competition is going to drive out this
new technology
around the world and so the focus really
is on
innovation meeting a need solving a
problem
you know and pomp when i talked about
the importance of modernizing the dollar
i don't propose to do that exclusive uh
or
an exclusion to the development of
private stable coins
private units of value or or even to
the existing accounts based system you
know whenever you roll out a new
technology
you leave the old technology in place if
nothing else for redundancy purposes
but also because it serves well what we
view is
choice in the marketplace is the best
way to advance the future and our
view of a digital dollar is to it's
about modernizing the dollar itself
without actually replacing elements
that will continue to serve for some
time to come
when you guys think about um kind of the
single most important
regulation that we should focus on uh
whether it's in the future or
today is there one thing that sticks out
head and shoulders above everything else
says hey
this is the thing that everyone should
be aware of this is the thing that
everyone should be paying attention to
uh or is it just a more of a kind of
diverse bag of so many different
uh pieces of regulation that we should
be uh paying attention to
so a lot of the um uh
overall approach and language of
regulation
that we've done in the united states is
based upon a brick and mortar mindset
and tends to regulate entities
as opposed to activities you know
traditionally
when when regulation comes to an
ecosystem it could be finance it could
be healthcare it could be any other
ecosystem
regulators traditionally look at the
ecosystem and say okay
where are the intermediaries where are
the key
collection points once we identify them
we're going to regulate them we're going
to
license them we're going to co-op them
to a certain degree and give them
responsibilities for data collection for
regulatory purposes
reporting obligations etc regulation
traditionally
identifies the brick and mortar
intermediaries and
subjects that are into licensure it's an
entity based approach
but as we go to a more decentralized
model
that approach really falls down and
becomes incapable
of bringing a sensible um a regulatory
uh uh infrastructure framework to bear
and what we need to do is
is is change our mindset from a brick
and mortar mindset an entity based
mindset
and start thinking about activities and
how do we bring
the right public policy to bear on
activities
in a decentralized world and i think
that's going to be the biggest challenge
for congress and regulatory agencies
to if we're going to bring a sensible
framework to bear on
this new digitization of finance we're
going to need to move beyond
an entity based approach and look at an
activities based approach
go beyond a a regulation of centralizers
toward a overall approach to a
decentralized environment i think it
it's going to take a sea change in
thinking but if we get that right it
could be enormously powerfully
boost forward for this wave of
innovation
[Music]
sorry no i was gonna ask you
specifically go ahead
okay the the structure of my concept are
is really
exactly like chris is just the different
dimensions so we talk about digital
assets or crypto assets
as as a set of one thing
but but really we have crypto asset
classes within that and we really start
we need to start um
interacting and operating with them as
such governance tokens
uh cryptocurrencies um
different uh classes of these digital
assets they have different risk
they have different people using them
they have different
capabilities some crew values some
generate cash flows
so we really need to think uh
broader than just the digital assets
as one class and look at crypto asset
classes
there's amazing things happening with
governance tokens
where you can think that the the
blockchain is generating
value well if the blockchain's
generating value the governance of
rights
the governance rights of that blockchain
are also occurring value
the ability to be able to vote we're
going into a world that
we're going to participate more with our
assets right we're going to be able to
vote we're going to be able to change
we'll upgrade and we're going to be in
more communities that are aligned on
objectives and we're going to be able to
coalesce as
as groups of people within
dow's decentralized you know autonomous
organizations
and corporations um and so uh
i think we really need to look at uh
crypto asset classes
i outline eight or ten in my book but
how they operate differently
how each of them accrue or create value
differently
and i suspect regulation will
want to have a distinct approach for
each
when you guys think through kind of the
way that regulators and innovators can
work together
this conversation is fascinating to me
because we have somebody who spent
a number of years running one of the
most important regulatory agencies
we have somebody who spent a bunch of
time building and investing
on the kind of private sector side how
do you see
folks like yourselves working together
for the kind of
benefit of the industry and really of
just progress
across the global technology landscape
you know pump when when i started the
cftc in 2014
uh after about a year or two there i
became very frustrated because i
innovators would call me up and say that
they had just conducted a visit to the
agency
and they weren't sure that
what they were talking about was really
appreciated and i said well who did you
meet with and they said well
after a couple of phone calls we
eventually got shuffled off to
the office of chief economist and i said
what were you doing
with the chief economist and they said
well it's the only one the agency
actually had that
could kind of speak our language about
technology
technology innovation and that was a
very unsettling
realization so um within a month of my
being named as chairman
i i called for the creation of something
we eventually named
lab cftc and and what we what the
purpose of it was
to create an office where innovators
could go
and speak to uh regulators who spoke
their language
understood technology understood what
they're trying to do and had authority
across the agency
to then work with them to bring them to
the right division or department in the
agency
where their innovation might come into
conflict with some of our regulation
and to have a two-way dialogue both so
that the innovators
could find a way forward but so that the
agency itself can understand
where its old and analog rule sets were
not actually allowing innovation to take
place and so lab cftc became sort of an
ombudsman
not just for the innovation community
but also for the regulatory community
to understand what was going on and
since then lebsen ftc has grown and
expanded
and really become the leader the
stakeholder within the agency
to champion innovation um and
and and it's a model that was the first
of its kind in the united states
but that other regulatory agencies have
since adopted i think it's one that i
strongly recommend for all regulators
you know if you think about our agencies
as big
limestone buildings our goal was to take
a sledgehammer and smash it an opening
in the wall that says innovators enter
here
and please come on and you're very
welcome to come in
and talk to us and that was that was
really one of the most important steps i
think we took amongst many
at the cftc to give us a more
forward-looking opportunity a long
more forward-looking approach to digital
innovation
jake anything to add to that yeah i mean
i think
as uh innovators and leaders in the
community
our job is education whether it's
through writing
articles and or books or really being
out there and being a voice
our job is to communicate what we need
right we can't just sit back and
and act as victims we have to be in act
you know in action and participate you
know it's going to take
a dialogue it's going to take uh
partnership and participation
and so um i think it's just important
for us to
to uh to be out to educate to speak what
we need and for us to work together
and and think about it as partnership
we're all uh committed to the same types
of ideas and values you know
we want to generate and have a better
u.s and world
and so um that happens through dialogue
got it before i finish up i always ask
everyone the same three questions and
these are a little bit fun
um and then i want to uh to close out
with you guys kind of both highlighting
uh the books
that you've either written or are going
to write but the first question is
what's the most important book that
you've ever read
you cannot answer with your own uh so
maybe jake we'll start with you what's
the most important book you've read i
think chris will go to you
i think the catalyst i mean it's it's a
simple book but yeah
i think rich dad poor dad really was the
catalyst for me and
whatever that was the late 90s or 2000s
so
um simple simple good ideas about being
an entrepreneur so rich dad poor dad
uh well thanks for making jake go first
on that may give me a chance to think
about
what's probably the most important book
but i think probably any of the books by
neil ferguson have really
influenced my thinking about the
importance
of currency and the importance of
modernization of currency as keyed to
any economic infrastructure which forms
a lot of my thinking about the
importance of a
of a us central bank digital currency
second question uh is a little bit more
personal it's about
sleep routine it's brought to you by our
friends over at eight sleep uh i've been
sleeping on their
thermoregulated bed which basically
means they just make it super super cold
uh and allows you to get a deeper sleep
uh but this was all after i used to be
like a five six hour sleep person now
i'm more of like an eight or nine hours
what is both of your sleep routines and
how has that changed over the years
uh you know i do some of my i i do some
of my best thinking
as i'm laying in bed sometimes at two or
three in the morning
and find myself running up to my home
office to jot down notes or sometimes
even
uh write some things i i i i don't sleep
as much as i used to i don't sleep as
soundly as i used to unfortunately but
i've turned that into
an opportunity to collect those thinking
and probably the book manuscript that
i'm working on
about this challenge of regulation in a
digital future
uh some of the probably the best at
least to me most satisfying passages
i've written between
the hours of three and five in the
morning
i i don't get a lot of sleep uh i do
have a sleep problem
uh i think the idea of cool is really
important
um i have had to get a routine to
slow the body and mind it's really for
me that the mind will not
just will not shut up will not stop so
um
i i have a routine i try to then listen
to the music
do some breath work and meditation and
then a friend of mine
makes some um like
from plants medicines that help kind of
you know dream and uh and so uh
sleep's so important and and i've been
uh
just trying to get more of a practice
around it so i can get better sleep
i will tell you pomp that my uh early
morning waking up served me very well as
chairman of the cftc because i'd use the
time to cha
ch check on asian markets and when i
arrived for my 8 a.m staff meeting
i would also be telling the staff have
you looked at this or look what's going
on here in japan and others
it helped us actually prepare for what
we can expect when the new york markets
and the chicago markets opened up later
in the day
i love it uh the last question i have uh
and then we'll talk about the books is
uh aliens are each of you a believer in
aliens or not a believer
i just think it would be amazing if
we're the only life form
in the universe so uh
where they are and what they're doing i
don't know but there's
got to be other life out in space and i
hope i'm alive when we actually come
into contact with them
someday in the future i think that would
be amazing
i absolutely do uh believe in aliens uh
for sure
it's just uh jake your uh kind of
delivery of that is just like yes i
absolutely believe
is uh is incredible uh before i let you
guys go i want each of you to talk about
uh
the books that you've either written or
you're in the process of writing now and
then where people can uh can go find
those
uh maybe jake will start with you and
then i think chris you can take us home
sure i i wrote a book called crypto
asset investing
in the age of autonomy it's published by
wiley it came out in december
you can get that at your favorite
independent bookstore or
on amazon and uh yeah
it's out in the public and ready to read
so pop i've been working on uh both a
narrative of the experience we had at
the cftc in overseeing the launch of
bitcoin futures and how that really was
a pretty close
run thing at some point uh we did that
despite full page ads in the wall street
journal from
some market makers telling us that if
bitcoin futures launched the world would
come to an end
and phone calls and please from overseas
regulators begging us not to
validate bitcoin that they saw the
launch of bitcoin futures would be
and so it was really uh uh sort of a
profile encourage i think for a number
of
my colleagues at the agency for that uh
that that launch and i think that launch
is critical and critical now for
the maturization of this asset class and
and the
drawing of uh investment grade uh
uh players into the space but also
really focusing on where we go from here
that the regulatory framework needs to
mature and take a more comprehensive
approach and that we really do need to
modernize
our our core nationally money
infrastructure and that is by
creating a digital dollar alongside with
our existing infrastructure
so uh i look forward to getting that
book out
uh later this year and
and i hope it'll be a good read for many
people following this program
absolutely you guys are absolutely
fantastic i really enjoyed this
conversation this is
an incredibly important topic uh maybe
just to finish this up
explain where uh people can get in touch
with either one of you if it's on social
media or somewhere else
if they've got any questions following
this conversation great
i i tweet at uh john carlo markets
john carlo mkts on twitter
and you can reach me through wookiefar
and gallagher
uh at chris johncarlo at wilkie.com
sorry
jc johncarlo wilkie.com
yes you can learn more about my book at
ageofautonomy.com
you can find me on twitter at tradecraft
jake
and if you want to know more about my
crypto fund you can go to
tradecraft.capital awesome guys listen
thank you so much i think people are
really going to enjoy this one i did and
we'll do it again in the
it future great